you
it's an animation apparel oh man that's
cool
always very impressed my animated shorts
people my missing home Oh
[Music]
so you your mom Holloway we were younger
we go outside
[Music]
hahahaha
ah she doesn't want to be friends with
her
I mean you do for those two little girls
do we are
[Music]
ah she's all beaten up oh she can handle
the abuse or he I don't know what it's a
guy right girl she know [ __ ] gender
hybrid
the child you should read you this whole
thing with dialogue start doing dumb I -
now I look a happy they are you found me
ah
haha yeah it'd sound really good time
all this kid looks forward to is
Halloween was she not impressed
[Music]
which just happened I just have
[Music]
oh don't wanna be friends
[Music]
yeah man he really likes that girl
nobody else appears - yeah just kind of
cold-hearted you know Oh party was that
don't party for Nia
[Music]
No
what the hell's going on with this girl
it's because there were a negative
energy man law of attraction dude told
the secret thought about was your lack
of candy
[Music]
whatever [ __ ] you like it maybe she's
depressed maybe but she does like that
guy she does the ride she would just be
tagged along give her some candy what is
the medical report say oh no she died
[Music]
imaginary friend ah poor kid
saterland success oh man
[Music]
you picked the most oppressed imaginary
friend you know maybe it is a
representation of what is going on
because he's depressed that he's trying
to make her feel better my turn making
him feel better
exactly Oh danger zone danger zone
[Music]
she's gonna kill herself oh no traps
dude kids not real man it's real to me
ah
he's fast
[Music]
ah ah
No
he's now the girl
home-tree
[Music]
this is too sad this is like a heart
wrench or this is like finding out
you're not real
Oh
[Music]
cut to reality snapback
[Music]
that cops heart get too excited don't
get too excited
[Music]
ah what happened what happened I got
nipple chills I don't know why he killed
the little girl last year wait a minute
wait no don't leave it so open to
interpretation it was there something
maybe miss no we were both watching they
killed a little girl or did he make up
an imaginary friend based on a little
dead girl he founded the ones oh yeah so
I'm wondering about if I miss that's it
oh she was a spirit spirit yeah okay
that seems like there no why did you
pick up on that that seems more like a
reasonable interpretation today yeah are
you so not quite an imaginary friend but
kind of that's why she was so sad yeah
cuz she couldn't be a piece you can find
her she was just a dead girl the wood
man dude that's just like that Reese
Witherspoon Mark Ruffalo movie and now I
get why she wasn't about how we like I
haven't been in time with you but this
is not the point
wait a minute though in the beginning of
it he's friends with her like he makes
friends with her and goes out to play
with her then it cuts to the a year
later and he's hanging out with her so
maybe like maybe he's somehow got her
killed
unless she's just been dead for years or
something you know got her killed maybe
maybe she died in the woods you know
maybe he killed her she did die in the
wood
I know maybe he killed with a little boy
a little John Humphrey it's so John it's
Little John Humphrey right side boy
that's the whole thing with you found me
I found you and all that because because
she takes a photo of the little girl I
almost feel like she probably died
around Halloween cuz like they're
missing picture of her like they're last
seen you know she's holding the costume
so she probably died wearing that
costume and every Halloween you know her
spirit roams life yeah and she finds the
one kid with nobody to hang with and
weeds because she was bullied too
properly yeah they can probably add
wondering how she died you know who
killed her and I think it was the little
boy it was a little John Humphrey I
don't thinks
I don't think that's Little John
Humphrey is a serial killer I don't get
why none of the comic boxes are saying
this you wanted to get caught this is
actually yeah we don't know kirbo me
yeah it's like I'm actually I want my
credit now yeah please acknowledge the
ingenuity of my current wanted to get
caught cause he has a bigger plan in
yeah getting caught was only a part of
only one part of the plan and my
intentional
well they lead everybody to the bike
it's the closure you know it's the I can
be free I think yeah it's just so hard
follow your love with a ghost have your
fell in love with a ghost
no what's not love of the corpse thing
can you elaborate not only I should Evan
told me this it's a dead body I found in
the held on to it for years I don't do
anything without permission and luckily
she never wrote their whole for whole
family
a lot of terrible is its header that's
not even against a terrible bad horrible
desert things that he dusting really
dude don't make fun of that there are
necrophiliacs in this life do you think
the candies were like a metaphor for
like sexual pleasure yes I think that's
the point that they want us to take home
I'm not really good at like interpreting
things you know like I don't know if
DiCaprio was still alive at the end of
Inception or if he was just sleepy know
what's going on there it really tired I
don't know if it's a dream or Naja in
Inception - he just wakes up he wakes up
just Goods him going about a normal baby
yes
I've slept for easels okay besides Cup
trying to interpret what it all meant
that the music was really delightful I
thought it was like a great silent like
towards the end you hear some dialogue
and [ __ ] Ben even most of it like like
2/3 of it at least is all music or maybe
more than 2/3 like 3/4 like 90% yes it
is for all intents and purposes like a
silent O piece yeah and it's cute it's
adorable it's still like a Halloween
focus is about a dead girl but it's not
like a scary short film though it's kind
of spooky in here you at the end it does
it's not all
blown-out horror on Halloween is kind of
like this gothic and kind of melancholy
it's like a melancholy Gothic romance
tale of children
I'll and I actually I love that kind of
thing like I love children in love I
love children and no no but like like
every once in a while you know I don't
think they make them as much anymore but
you you will have like stories about
like romantic stories but about you know
children in a fantastical situation of
some kind and I always I don't know
those like resonate with me for whatever
reason and I really like this and I
really like to tone that the music
establishes and I really love the
animation style - yeah the animation
style was brilliant it has that tangible
feel to it with the flicker and the
grain and all that like it's like the
French cartoon meets an animated like
kinda ibrid into one I don't know how
they made this exactly but it feels like
an actual animation project that
somebody animated you know instead just
like laughing yeah like it looks like
everything was hand-drawn like I was
yeah it feels like a lot of care went
into this and I there's a lot of emotion
in it that there's a lot of motion and
and and there's a lot of very beautiful
imagery and resonant it's simple and
sweet you know I thought it was very I
thought it was like very adorable and
this is not something I'll forget no I
actually got really glad what everything
- yeah yeah this is something I would
like repost every now and again just to
be like guys this is lovely
yeah kind of sad but it's also great I
mean how many of us have been in this
exact situation as this little kid most
of my friends most of my friend I've
been like yeah this all I do is just set
people free to go on into the afterlife
it's like the good luck Chuck of corpses
so you just have sex with it I don't
have any selling - your love you guys
are good luck Chuck that's kind of the
plot hey buddy hey or girl whoever you
are I don't notice your gender subscribe
today please John
Boop Reese's Jared Twitter Instagram -
social media manager of facebook.com
slash blue house when I give a shout out
here night mist five six one nine zero
donated eight thousand one hundred stars
- it night miss what a perfect name for
a shout out for this specific video you
know night mist
you know I feel like a ghost gets misty
at night if you know what I mean yeah
yeah totally
cuz like nights have fog during them and
air has more wanted kind of joke oh is
that the guy - Joe of a guy a guy no Joe
I need Joe biorhythm same guy Doug if I
ever take up turntablism my name will be
DJ night miss oh I'll be cool I make
every mystical Beast
five six one nine zero that is code for
um it's just my zip code I don't know
when I might have a goes for sex or poop
haha that's code for nothing else is
funny how thanks your poop right good
then zero and so okay so it's like one
person kind of crunches over well the
next person kind of you know it's a lot
of configuration why it's a it's a
complicated name my friend for your
shadow I'm sorry